l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines a peut-être trouvé sa nouvelle
locomotive avec un mètre 93 pour 76 kg à
seulement 16 ans babacar diop possède un
gabarit hors du commun
cet hiver il bat le record de france du
400 mètres cadet alors qu'il s'aligne
sur le tour de piste depuis à peine une
saison c'est dire le talent du gamin
pourtant son entraîneur philippe
lefebvre la ligne seulement sur le 200 m
aux championnats de france
résultat babacar et titré et améliore
son record personnel
c'est particulier mais en même temps je
reste à ma venue parce que c'était en
salle on sait pas encore ce qui se passe
de l'espace est dehors et tu penses que
tu as encore une marge de progression
justement
moi je pense vraiment pas ce que concède
le coach pas encore habitués avec les
lactique et on t'en étais en salle c'est
plus difficile pour moi des poésies
légende
derrière le jeune baba car tout le monde
se tire vers le haut à l'image de
jeffrey levac vice champion de france
espoirs sur le 200 m ces résultats
exceptionnels prennent leur source dans
la cohésion du groupe très travaillée à
l'entraînement avec le relais et la
mayonnaise n'est pas prêt de redescendre
c'est bon moi je me regarde je souhaite
ce à tous les entraîneurs on a vraiment
un groupe là où ils ont des qualités
ils s'entraînent dans la joie dans le
plaisir ça rigole plus qu'autre chose
mais je dis tant mieux parce que donc on
fait beaucoup de séances où on fait du
relais l'aspect collective de l'athlé
puisse préjuger et puis un jour ils
m'amènent un de leurs copains ils
violent qui a lui aussi on le connaît
bien il convient de ne pas essayer pas
fuit les haïssent met dedans on a à peu
près tous le même âge donc on se suit
forcément sur chaque année et c'est vrai
que depuis qu'on a à peu près 16 7 ans
ont fait de bons résultats et c'est vrai
que voir les autres faire de bons
résultats ça nous pousse aussi être le
meilleur pour la suite quoi après cette
nouvelle moisson médaille le plus dur
commence pour le meilleur club du
département garder ses pépites sur les
pistes saint-quentinoise